[Music]
all right let's go to
mark in los angeles california what is
up mark hi there dr looney thanks for
having me
what's up man how are you i'm doing all
right how are you
i'm doing good so how can i help man
so recently i found out that a few years
before meeting my wife
she was working as an escort and
she had kept this a secret from me and i
can understand why she didn't want me
knowing about it
she told me she hated it it's something
she was ashamed of
maybe a little traumatized by it
she did it for the money she had debt
and eventually she got addicted to the
lifestyle
and continued to do it and now
we're married and we're expecting a baby
and i love my wife and i want to accept
it and move on
but uh you know it's kind of a tough
pill to swallow
and i'm not even really sure how i
should feel about it
and i'm just wondering how i can move
forward
without that image of the past painting
our relationship
and getting in the way of our marriage
oh that's a lot brother
that is a lot thanks for sharing that
how long you have been married
uh only a couple months uh only a few
months huh
and how far along is little baby
uh about 25 weeks 25 weeks
wow okay is it becoming real yet you're
about to be a dad
yeah it's uh definitely real but i'm
excited for it
that's awesome man poof okay so
you said you don't know how to feel what
you should feel about this
so tell me what do you feel about this
be honest as you can
don't lie to me or yourself or to the 17
or 18 listeners of the show
i think the first thing i felt was no no
no no
don't don't start with i think how do
you feel
i feel lied to deceived
okay maybe jealous okay
hurt angry
yeah what else
i think i i'm sorry i feel
it's definitely got in the way of my
trust
yeah you think yeah
what else
i don't know i think there's just so
many different
things going in my mind i don't know
where to even begin
so just begin
don't overthink it
yeah i'm saying just begin
you're angry you're pissed off you're
heartbroken you're just sad
okay what kept you from just what kept
you from just packing up and walking out
the door
most of us the story we would tell
ourself is if one day our wife
sat down and said bt dubs i was an
escort before we
um got married but it's all good now
pass the syrup we would the story we
tell ourselves that we'd be like i'm out
of there bro i'm out
you didn't do that how come
uh i love her i mean you've had a good
relationship so far
not the best it's had its rocky points
but well it's built on
it was yeah you know what i mean so
yeah i would imagine it's like saying
man yeah the
the the our boat trip was pretty rocky
and it's like yeah there's big holes in
that boat full of water
could see that um
how long did y'all date before you got
married uh
it's been about a year now okay
and
so you love her you've known her for
about a year
you got married you're having a baby
what do you want to do
i i want to make this relationship work
this is something in her past and i
don't really have a reason
not to i don't really have a reason to
believe it was something that
has happened since we've been together
and she's been good to me and i want to
take care of the family
is she in on this too
yeah she's in 100
how'd you find out
so when we got married we had uh
our own hard drives like our own files
on our computers and we
put them onto one and so just one day i
was going through and i found some old
photos and
uh like messages
from the agencies
what was that feeling like
it was uh like my heart sank
yeah that's when you can feel your
organs fall out of the bottom of your
you
just sit there and your stomach drops
so so i found out and then i i
asked her about it that night and she
was a little hesitant she didn't want to
talk about it but
uh since then she's been completely
honest as far as i'm as i know
okay and i think the key here is as far
as you know
okay so here's the reality of your
situation
and it sounds sensational right most of
us don't wake up
and uh the person we married a few
months in lets us know or we find out
that they used to be
um an escort right prostitute
that right um that doesn't usually
happen
but almost always not almost always but
often
you wake up and you find things out
about your
spouse they had a pass they didn't tell
you they're full of this
they didn't think to even explain that
they didn't think this was a big deal or
whatever that happens to be
so at the end of the day here's what
you're wrestling with you're wrestling
with
two things one a shattered picture
of the woman you just married the future
mother of your kid
and of this um
this um fantasy of marriage that you had
right and two you're dealing with a
significant violation of trust
so the violation of trust is something
you're gonna have to
lean into be honest about and continue
to work towards healing
right and she's gonna have to understand
that she violated that trust
if you say i forgive you if you say i am
fully in
and i love you and we are moving forward
then you're not going to be able to beat
her up on this deal you're not going to
bring it up when you get mad five years
from now
you're gonna have moments of insecurity
you're gonna have moments of
when she's late coming home and you're
gonna have to choose to not
use those moments as weapons because you
said i forgive you and you said i'm all
in
and as part of the rebuilding trust
process
you're gonna be able to say hey i'm just
checking in you're late coming home
everything good
and that she's gonna know that part of
her rebuilding trust process
is being completely open and not getting
her feelings hurt when you ask her to
check in
okay you got a lot of healing right
and that's going to be frustrating and
hard and messy you know going to stumble
through that but if you're both all in
you're both all in
right the second part of this
is your picture looks all screwed up
right she's not who you thought she was
yeah
right we all have a past right we
weren't all prostitutes but we all have
a past
right that just sounded
bonkers to even say out loud so what
you're gonna have to do is sit down and
with her
and co-create a new picture what this is
gonna look like
right and if i'm with you
she's a person of value she's worthy of
being loved too
and if she's put her past behind her and
she's moving on
in a committed relationship with you and
you are the
end-all be-all then she deserves
forgiveness and moving on just like
anybody else does
but there's a part of me that says you
don't trust her yet that you're not
ready to paint a whole new picture with
her included in it because she meh
right and so that's gonna at those
building a new
painting a new picture together building
a new building and
working on that trust is gonna be like
an infinity signal it's gonna work
together
you have to keep working on this and
keep working on it and then brother you
just have to grieve
because you got a picture of what was
and it's gone now and now you know
something new
right scales came off your eyes and now
you got a new new vision of what's
what's going forward
and you're going to have to grieve that
man just be open about it
and so this is going to be hard yet the
the things to do are relatively simple
it's gonna be getting up every day and
remembering to respect her and be kind
to her not weaponize her and love her
like she's your wife because she is like
she's the future mother of your baby
which she
is and it's gonna be honest and open
about rebuilding trust
so how does that sound that's not
something you want to do be a part of
yeah you're right that uh that trust is
still hard to get back but
i think at this point uh it's
she is the future so i want to do
anything i can
so you mentioned something earlier you
said uh
you were jealous what does that mean
i um just that image of
that past work it's i think it's getting
in the way of the intimacy
yep obviously
i wasn't in the picture but
it's just having that thought is it
getting in the way of your intimacy
the you're starting to put these images
in on loop
replay replay how do you measure up
how many were there where were they i
wonder if she tried this
are you going down that road yeah all of
that
yeah so hey listen
there is no fruit in detail mining
if she sat there and gave you a rundown
of every single trick she ever turned
if she gave you a run down in a physical
description of every person she was ever
with
it wouldn't make you feel better
and this is gonna be part of your
healing process which is to let some of
that stuff go and what you're gonna have
to do is practice
practice controlling your thoughts when
you go down those roads
because what's going to lead you to be
highly insecure
highly frustrated never being able to be
in the present moment with her because
the moment that one thought pops in your
head i wonder if she was somebody else
did this or i wonder if i wonder if
this could have then you are officially
not present anymore and you are
somewhere in her imagined past
right right and so you're gonna have to
work hard
that when that image pops in your head
you say out loud nope
and you have another image ready to go
to which is probably her staring right
back at you
but we have this fantasy that if we just
know every detail
all right good it's not true same thing
happened with folks
um you know when somebody takes their
own life they want to know why and what
happened and uh
and you can learn all that stuff it
never takes away that hurt
never takes away that that feeling of
loss right
and how does she respond when you tell
her that you're struggling with
things with thoughts of jealousy and
your imagination runs wild on you
she's pretty understanding but
it's not something she really enjoys
talking about
it's gotten a little a little heated
yeah
and does it feel good to bring it up
maybe at first but i i don't think it
ever ends well
yeah you know what it's like it's like
throwing a punch feels good and if it
connects solid brother
man it feels good for one second
and then you see their look on their
face you see them fall to the ground
and your takes over right that
don't turn around this whole thing
around and you put yourself in some sort
of superior position and beat her up
with her past
if you say you're all in you're all in
you've got to put your bricks down too
brother you're bricks of insecurity your
bricks are not enough you're bricks of
moral superiority well i never did this
you're right you didn't
congratulations you said i'm all in
right right so in the same way that
you have to rebuild trust with her she's
gotta rebuild trust with you
slowly but surely you're gonna have to
relearn how to trust yourself
you're gonna have to relearn how to
treat people
when you get angry you're gonna have to
learn some new behaviors and new skills
ones that where you don't
yell and raise your voice and get all
high and mighty and superior and yeah
yeah yeah well you don't do any of that
and it's gonna be a hard journey for
both of you and
sounds like this is relatively recent
that you found out
this grief's gonna come in waves it's
gonna come in waves
just like the last caller if y'all are
both all in
i have no doubt in my mind y'all can
heal from this grow
and make this a powerful part of your
journey
powerful story and there's also no doubt
in my mind that if at any moment one of
you is like
dips her toe back in the water this
whole boat's gonna flip right over
easy over you get to make that choice
brother
man i'm all in on you guys good for you
um i'm all in let me know how it goes
let me know how those hard conversations
go and keep me updated man
let us know when the baby's born and
we'll keep thinking about you all in
your journey